pour vos vacances n'hésitez plus
direction la bosnie owni aviez jamais
pensé et bien cet homme qui dirige une
petite agence de voyages vous propose de
vivre l'histoire en direct
on peut même aller suivre ce qui se
passe avec le sandero nominaux et les
narcotrafiquants au pérou ou au
nicaragua quand il n'y a pas tellement
de conditions de sécurité bien sûr
puisque on est dans des domaines qui
sont pas sûrs absolument nous avons en
services de sécurité qui va nous suivre
pendant tout le voyage nous aurons
médecin avec nous avec l'équipement pour
fred up et puis c'est tout déjà une
dizaine de clients se sont inscrits pour
connaître le grand frisson
mais le plus curieux c'est que ce client
mon père de famille y voit aucun
inconvénient
ça m'intéresse de voir la guerre j'ai
toujours entendu parler de la guerre
mais je n'y ai jamais assisté vraiment
directeur cela risque de l'intéressé
beaucoup moins quand il apprendra quand
ce genre de voyage coûte aux alentours
de 150 me inconscience provocation
massimo baierlé ne recule devant rien il
avait déjà organisé une croisière pour
femmes célibataires en mal de mal
amour et voyeurisme des recettes qui
marche à tous les coups je croyais que
s'il y avait un côté mace j'aurais pas
fait ça
on sonne d'accord non je ne suis pas
d'accord moi et vous mais d'après moi
aller dans de tels envois cela devrait
servir à aider les gens mais pas faire
un voyage d'agrément maximou réfléchit à
d'autres idées
mais déjà on craint le pire